>>Jim Palmer: Welcome, everyone.
I'm Jim Palmer, head of the Android user experience
team.
Let me just say, it's so exciting, being a
designer here at the conference, to see so
many people coming out to see a design session.
So, wow, thanks for all the support there.
[ Applause ]
>>Jim Palmer: Our session today is on Android
UI design patterns.
We're truly excited about the growth of Android
and, of course, all the applications you are
doing.
But, really, stop by the developer sandbox
and check out the wall of phones.
Does anyone doubt that touch-based mobile
devices are going to dominate the next generation
of computing products; right?
This is where it's at.
So we're really excited to be here and to
help you guys deliver that vision.
Today, after my intro, we're going to go through
some of the new patterns that we've been exploring
on your team, give you a few tips on visual
design and end with a walk-through of an app
that will tie it all together.
What's in it for you?
Insight about where we're headed, as well
as some practical advice on creating a better
Android app.
Of course, this being Google, it wouldn't
be right if we didn't have a little nerdy
question along the way.
So while we're going through the presentation,
see if you can spot a term, it's a figure
of speech from classical rhetoric.
In the Q&A, we'll give out a collectible to
someone who can name that.
Okay. So let's go into the session here.
Since I/O last year, a lot has happened with
Android.
You guys are aware of the releases: Donut,
Eclair, an update of Eclair for the Nexus
One, as well as the upcoming Froyo.
One of the key things that's happened, however,
from a user experience point of view has been
the support for more hardware profiles and
specifically for different screen sizes and
densities.
As you can see, those wall of devices out
there show why that's been such a great boon
for us.
From the G1, which is a half-VGA screen at
approximately 180 dpi, we've added two versions
of WVGA at around 240, 250 dpi.
So as a result, we've tried to optimize the
system to allow assets to be targeted to each
of those to make them better.
So we're going to talk about that today.
Another big change, of course, has been the
explosion of apps in the developer community.
I just want to let you know, we do pay attention
to what's going on there, both how you're
using the existing tools we're providing as
well as new challenges that you're trying
to solve and incorporating those.
I think you'll see with some of our patterns
we're adopting that and moving that forward.
So, let's give some context before we dive
into the actual session.
People ask, what is your UI group's philosophy
for design on Android?
To start, we want to be somewhat heretical
here and challenge the common view that a
good UI is simple.
While appealing in concept, simple has a negative
connotation in some ways.
It can mean lack of power, inability to adapt
or grow.
In particular, this notion is often in UI
circles operationalized as counting number
of clicking or number of touches as if by
measuring that, you're going to ensure that
you're going to have a usable product.
I submit that, in fact, that what makes UIs
usable is being clear, which is being confused
leads to frustration and a general sense of
I don't know how to use this product.
And that's what hurts you more than total
number of clicks.
So, for sure, overloading on features or having
too many complex interactions are bad.
But by focusing on clarity over simplicity,
we can get products, we think, that are both
straightforward to use and powerful.
So that's one of the things that we think
about.
Another part of our philosophy is to use as
much of the screen as possible to what people
really care about, which is content, and,
specifically, their content, whether it's
photos, music, status updates, messages.
You know, of course we want to increase the
clarity of the UI by putting common actions
on screen as clickable items.
And we're going to talk about that today as
a pattern.
But more and more, content on the screen itself
can drive interaction, not just traditional
UI controls.
And why is this important?
Over time, we're going to try to work on reducing
the visual complexity of screens, you know,
the boxes within boxes and all the lines.
So that will help also make it feel lighter.
This tension, then, between content and UI
Chrome often gets played out in discussions
about consistency.
Is the UI consistent?
In the worst case this means let's make everything
the same so people know what to do.
What we're going to promote in our group is
interaction consistency, that is, making it
clear to users what they can do, without being
monotonous.
Herb Simon, one of the founders of cognitive
psychology, once said, "Information consumes
attention."
And with all the options and choices available
to users today, products need to focus on
engaging their users.
So by keeping the interaction consistent,
but varying the treatment and adding visual
expression and visual delight, you can draw
users in and really engage them in your product.
Finally, mobile devices are the very definition
of personal.
We have them with you at all times.
You use them constantly.
So people do a lot of experimenting, both
trying out new devices, downloading apps,
trying out the app.
What they don't want to do and don't have
time to do is constantly reorganize the stuff.
They want to organize their stuff once, and
they expect to be able to use that organization
in future contexts.
So any time spent adapting a product to a
user they expect to leverage in the future.
Thus, applications should use the cloud as
the glue that lets users stay in context and
not constantly recreate their context, you
know, having to set stuff up and reestablish
what they use on the desktop or in other places.
So the cloud becomes not just a source of
information, but also a way to enhance the
user experience by cutting down the amount
of time and focusing on what's important to
them.
So, to conclude, here's a great insight from
Socrates, mere knowledge of the truth does
not give you the art of persuasion.
That obviously applies to how you motivate
people to act.
In this context, I want you to think of design
as a communication between you and your user
and help you move beyond just thinking of
mere functionality, but how you persuade people
to try and then stay engaged in your products.
So how do you do that?
Let's find out.
Let's dive in and I'm going to bring up Richard
Fulcher and we're going to start with the
next section on design patterns.
>>Richard Fulcher: Thank you, Jim.
And thanks to everybody who is here today.
So design patterns.
What do we mean when we say that?
Well, a UI design pattern really isn't all
that different from a software design pattern
as you know it today.
It's just a general solution to a recurring
problem.
It's not necessarily the perfect solution.
But it's a good, solid, reliable, broadly
applicable solution.
These patterns emerge just kind of as a part
of the design process.
You know, we do a few different things at
Google that help us generate these designs.
One of them is that we do both formal user
research, and we do what we call internal
dogfooding, where we'll do an early version
of an application, we'll share it with team
members kind of outside our immediate team
and we'll generate feedback that way.
We'll start to see what things work and what
things don't work so well inside the application.
Another way is that anytime you sit UI designers
together and they can kind of look at each
other's screens, you tend to get this certain
-- certain solutions tend to win.
You know, I might look over at something Chris
or Christian has done, and I'll look at it
and I'll think to myself, "Somebody call a
doctor, because that is sick!"
The last, and most important way that we see
patterns emerge is what we see you, the broad
development community, come up with.
We look at the market.
We see things within it that challenge us,
that inspire us.
And those help us to think about, well, either
here's a problem or here's a really interesting
way of solving it.
So for the patterns that I'm going to go through
today, we'll just have a little bit of detail
on each.
We'll give it a title so we can kind of refer
to them in a really strict vocabulary.
We'll give a couple of on-screen examples.
And these will just be very generic, low-fidelity
wire frames, because we're focusing on the
interaction at this point, not, ultimately,
the visual.
We'll state the problem that it's trying to
address and we'll give a number of recommendations
for each pattern.
So the five patterns I'm going to cover are
the dashboard, the action bar, the search
bar, quick actions, and the companion widget.
So first up is the dashboard.
So for all the examples we'll show here, I've
just kind of created this false, fake application.
You know, it's some kind of tool for people
who are passionate about Android to get together
and share updates and share product reviews.
So we've got this Android fanatics application,
and we're seeing the dashboard here in two
different flavors.
Portrait on the left; landscape on the right.
The dashboard's trying to address the question
of what can I do with this app, and what's
new with this app.
So it's really just a quick introduction to
the app that tries to lay out the key functionality
and give the user kind of clear waypoints
into the particular subtasks that the app
can perform for them.
You might think of it in a way as kind of
the hero screen shot of the application you
a might upload to the market when your app
is finished.
What's the one picture a user could look at
as they're kind of quickly flipping through
all the apps in the market that will kind
of stop them and say, okay, I get what this
is going to do.
This will do these things for me.
Okay, I kind of got it.
It's full screen, so you've got lots of real
estate.
And there's different ways that you can organize
it.
The example I just showed, it's kind of broken
up by features.
You're seeing kind of different entry points
to, you know, posting a review or search.
But you could also imagine doing it if you're
more content-focused, maybe it's by category,
where your dashboard is talking about top-rated,
or most popular, or recently added.
Or if you are more kind of productivity-focused,
it might be broken up by account.
You know, maybe you're an e-mail client or
an IM client that supports multiple accounts.
And then the dashboard could be used to display
those.
Recommendations for using a dashboard.
So do highlight what's new.
A good way to think of it is -- go back to
the example -- you know, think about a restaurant
that you really enjoy going to.
You go to the restaurant, and you have the
menu.
And that doesn't tend to change over time.
But you'll sit down at your table and get
a set of specials.
The screen is trying to kind of play both
of those.
You know, the top part is fixed, reliable,
you know where things are, you know how to
get to it.
The bottom part, show a little update, something
that's new for this user, back to the notion
of content specific for the user.
Or if you don't have that, if that's not appropriate
for your application, is there a new feature?
Is there something new for the kind of broad
community of users of your app that you can
call their attention to?
Do focus on just the most important choices
that the user can make.
The guidance we give here is, three to six.
Internally, we kind of call that set of icons
the six-pack, it's a two by three or two by
three arrangements of up to six items.
It's trying to convey the most important things
your app does.
And be flavorful.
This is one of the rare chances inside your
app where you have a lot of screen real estate
to play with for kind of showcasing the brand,
the identity.
Like, if you're a service or you're a companion
app for a service, showcase that.
The next pattern is the action bar.
You've seen this pattern in the -- the I/O
conference app, in fact.
So the action bar is that top area of the
screen, kind of that light blue box on the
far left, you can imagine that being the application
icon.
It's got a title.
And then at right, it's got a set of actions.
The action bar is trying to solve the question
of, well, how can I do app- -- or task A quickly?
It's a fixed set of real estate at the top
of the screen.
It can -- it should show up through most of
the content inside your app.
It's not exactly a Toolbar.
We're not going to put every item on there.
It's also not a replacement for the menu.
It's really just to take a few items and elevate
them.
It replaces the title bar.
You can kind of include the title inside of
that so you kind of swap the quick action
bar for a title bar.
It's best for actions that span across your
app.
Some candidates might be things like search
that you want available for a variety of contexts.
Refresh.
Maybe you always want to have a way to compose
a new piece of content related to your app
from any context.
You can also use it to provide a quick link
back up to the dashboard.
So you can, you know, imagine just users from
the Web are familiar with this notion of kind
of clicking at the upper left of a page on
a logo to go back to the home of that app.
We have the same affordance here.
A few recommendations.
So, again, use it to bring just the key actions
on screen.
A good litmus test would be, you know, what
are the actions that the user shouldn't have
to press menu to get at inside of my app?
Just bring those handful forward.
We tend to try to keep it to three or less
as the guidance, just to make it kind of very
obvious.
Use the action bar to give a sense of place.
You know in Android that it's very easy to
kind of teleport from place -- from app to
app to app following a series of intents.
Using that action bar at the top, just kind
of brand your app, let the user know where
they've landed after following this intent
helps give the user a sense of where they
are and where they can back away from.
Use it consistently.
So if you're going to put the action bar in
there, it should show up on most screens in
your app.
And also, if you're going to have actions
in the action bar, you know, order them consistently,
try to use them in the same pattern.
Don't have search move from here to there
as we move from one screen to another.
And then, finally, don't use it for contextual
actions.
We have another pattern that we'd like you
to consider for that.
And that's quick actions.
So two examples here for quick actions.
On the left, you're seeing kind of a quick
action popping up for an update that someone
from the Android fanatics community has posted.
On the right, you're seeing another quick
actions popup, but this time, coming out of
the contact frame, the image of the person
that posted it.
Quick actions are just a quick way to say,
well, what can I do with this thing?
You have a distinct target on the screen that
the actions are emerging from.
In the case of the one on the left here, there's
actually a target on the right-hand side that
just looks like the "more" button that the
user can tap and up come the quick actions.
On the one on the right, just press on the
user's picture. Up come the quick actions.
The reason the visual target is important
is we have seen at Android there is immense
power to contextual actions, and once people
can get I can long press on things to do more
things with the thing, they enjoy that.
A lot of people never get to that stage or
they are just not fully conscious of it and
just don't think of it in all the different
contexts it can appear.
So giving you an on-screen target lets you
know there's something I can do here.
We try to make them minimally disruptive to
the screen context. They are kind of popping
above or below the item they are acting on.
They don't cover up the item like a traditional
contextual items dialogue would.
And the actions themselves should be pretty
straightforward. Ideally you can communicate
them with just an icon or with an icon and
just a word or two of labels.
You want the actions to be really immediate
and obvious, just so as they pop up -- you
don't want the user to get into this case
of thinking about, well, what are all the
things I could do? Again, focus on the most
obvious things that they might want to do.
And it should be fast and fun. If any of you
were in the talk earlier today, there was
a presentation that a couple of designers
from YouTube gave about a positive user experience
and they laid out seven principles. And the
first principle was to be fast.
They actually said that fast is the most important
feature. I wouldn't argue that right now,
but I think there's a lot of value to fast.
And they kind of made a good argument that
fast is good for both new users who don't
understand why a product would be slow and
are ready to just sort of back away if a product
is not responsive as well as for veteran users
who just want to get through it.
So quick actions hopefully serve both of those.
Recommendations for quick actions. These are
gait when you have competing internal targets.
If we go back to the example here, for this
update, you have a lot of, things going on.
You have the person who updated it, you have
the text of their update, you have the time.
Their update may contain hyperlink or other
things.
If we take the example on the right and I
want to tap on Brandi Shaffer's update. The
fact that that URL there actually is a big
target, so where am I going to press if I
don't want to follow the link but I actually
want to do something like forward this whole
update to a friend. Giving a distinct target
on the side for doing something with the update
and a separate target for an update and a
link on the left for do something with this
person helps resolve that.
You should only import -- present it for the
most important and obvious actions. You can
use it when there's no kind of further detail
view for an item. Something like a list of
songs. If I press on a song, I'm off to now
playing and the music is starting but there's
kind of no other stuff about the song.
I could use a quick action to bring up rating
or recommend this to a friend, things like
that.
And don't use it in contexts where you have
multiple selection. A good example is maybe
an e-mail client where you have got kind of
a list of messages. There, if you look at
the way we have approached e-mail and Gmail
on the devices, we give you a set of leading
check boxes. You can hit those check boxes,
and then once something is selected, a bottom
button bar appears at the bottom of the screen
which gives you actions you can take on that
selection state. Either use that system or
use quick actions, but try not to mix the
two.
The fourth pattern I would like to talk about
today is the search bar. So two examples here.
In the left one, an empty search has come
up and the user has just pressed on the icon
to the left of the search field. And then
they have gotten a pop-up selector, which
looks a lot like the quick actions pop-up,
for choosing what search mode they would like
to use, whether they would like to search
friends or add reviews.
On the right, we have got a query that's in
progress. The user started typing, and suggestions
are starting to be presented.
So the search bar addresses the problem of
how can I find something. It anchors to the
top of the screen. So if you are using an
action bar, the search bar replaces that same
real estate. Just flip it in.
It should support suggestions. And you can
also use what we call the corpora selector
to change the search mode. It's the pop-up
I talked about.
Not all are apps are going to have multiple
search modes, and even those that do, you
might choose to not use that selector and
instead just have an item up here in the suggestions
list that offers pivoting to the other search
mode.
A few suggestions. Do use the search bar for
simple searches. Let's go back to the song
list we were talking about. That could be
a long list. If you are one of the attendees
who got a Motorola Droid, you might think
if I am trying to find a particular song I
can open up the keyboard and start typing
and it will filter to it. And that will work
if you are on a keyboard.
If you are on the Nexus One, there's a work-around
for that. You can lean on the menu button
and the keyboard will come up but not everybody
realizes that. So using the search bar to
just kind of say there's a way you can search,
even if it just does a simple filter of the
list, can provide value to the user.
Present rich suggestions. Don't just give
the label. Give some secondary bits of information.
If I am in that song list, it kind of matters
whether I am getting Pink Floyd's "Money"
or Eddie Money's "Money." So give that second
bit of info.
And then use the behavior consistently. You
might have the search button on the screen.
You might have a search hard key on your device,
depending on the manufacturer. You might even
have search within the menu. Those should
all go to the same place. They should all
make the search bar appear.
The last pattern I will cover is the companion
widget.
So here I have done a kind of four-by-one
widget for the Android fanatics app. So it
shows you how many new updates you have got,
the most recent update that's come in, and
there is a quick link for composing a message.
So the companion widget tries to address the
question of how can I make this app kind of
a fun part of my home experience? So it's
trying to support the app by bringing some
of its content and capabilities forward into
the home screen. When the user is at the home
screen, they don't always necessarily know
what they want to do. Sometimes they are just
browsing. This is your opportunity for the
app to kind of go, "Pick me, pick me!"
And also, companion widget makes home feel
more custom, more personalized. We hear repeatedly
from users that one of the things that they
appreciate most about the Android experience
is how much control we give them over their
home; that we let them have different wallpapers,
even live wallpapers; that we let them put
lots of interesting shortcuts; that they have
folders; that they have widgets; that they
don't have to just kind of put things in a
square grid that works from left to right.
Anything you can do to kind of foster that
is playing to something users already value.
So a few recommendations. Do provide value
above a simple app icon. Bring forward that
user content.
Don't try to do everything in a widget. It's
okay to have pointers into tasks, but once
the users pick that, take them into your app
to do that. The compose link is a good example
there. They hit compose, take them into your
app, take them into the part of the app that
has the compose activity and let them work
from there.
Be space efficient. If you want to do a large
widget, cool. But also think about offering
a smaller variant widget that users are more
concerned about how constrained their space
is on home. And don't just be a large app
launcher.
So wrapping these all together. Some of the
interaction that goes into building a really
good Android app, you've got a widget that
can feed you into your app. You have the dashboard
that lays out all the things your app can
do. From the dashboard, you may have an action
bar or you may go into other screens that
support the action bar. Action bar might pivot
off to search. And then individual screens
can support quick actions for the items the
items that you display there.
Thank you for your attention.
Now that we have covered some of the interaction
stuff, I want to welcome Christian Robertson
to the stage to talk a little bit about visual
design.
[ Applause ]
>>Christian Robertson: Okay. So Jim started
off by talking about a lot of things that
have changed since the last I/O with Android,
and there's a lot of exciting things going
on. And one of the things that we're really
excited about is the number of new and diversity
of devices that have been launched.
And at the same time, we're aware that this
causes some challenges for designers and developers,
creating Android applications.
In particular, there are some new screen sizes
to consider. Now, if you were in the last
session, you may have heard a bit about the
idea of pixel density. We find that as we
are talking with developers, this is one of
the places where we get the most questions,
is how does pixel density work.
So if you can see this example that I have
up on the screen, you can see that on the
left, we have a device that the screen size
is about 3.inches, on the right, 3.2 inches,
but you will also notice that the device on
the left has more than double the number of
pixels.
So Android is aware of this difference in
pixel density and classifies devices that
have a lot of pixels in a small space as hdpi,
or high density devices, and likewise there's
a classification for mdpi, or medium density,
and even ldpi for low density.
The idea here is we want to keep assets at
roughly the same physical size. So, for example,
if you design icons to fit human sized fingers
for -- let's say it's a Hero device and take
and run your application then on a Nexus One,
you want the icon to be the same physical
size and still match the size of real human
fingers.
So Android does some things behind the scenes.
One thing that it does is it will auto scale
assets from an mdpi asset, and scale those
up for hdpi screens. So you can see we have
two assets here. The left one is hdpi, the
right one is mdpi. And notice the one on the
right as it's scaled up to the same size is
a lot blurrier.
So Android has some features that deal with
that.
What this looks like for developers is, if
you just take a look here, I have got an additional
directory that I have added for my hdpi drawables.
And if I name the icons or the assets the
same thing, then Android will do the right
thing and swap out those higher density assets.
So this adds a little bit of extra work to
the development process, but we feel it's
worth it to really take advantage of these
amazing high resolution screens.
So what does the work flow look like from
an asset production standpoint? It's pretty
straightforward. I'll walk you through and
point out a couple potential pitfalls.
So let's say that this is my mdpi asset that
I want to resize. I am going to scale it up.
Now, the magic number here is 150%. So if
I scale by a factor of 1.5, then my mdpi assets
will be the correct size for hdpi.
Now, one thing to note is that it's a lot
easier if you are scaling up assets that are
vector based already. So whether you are using
PhotoShop or Inkscape or whatever, starting
with vectors makes it easier later on of and
if you have assets where you only have bitmap
source, you might need to reauthor.
So I am going to scale this up and things
look pretty good. PhotoShop's sample algorithm
in this case is pretty decent. You will notice,
though, that sometimes when you scale up one
pixel lines that things might get a little
bit fuzzy and you might need to clean those
things up. So this is especially true for
Nine-Patch images. If you scale up the tick
marks, you will have to clean up those tick
marks; otherwise, your Nine-Patches won't
work.
And that's it for supporting multiple screen
sizes.
So another thing that's changed in the last
year is we have launched a new style for our
icon guidelines.
Now, as we have watched what happened in the
marketplace, we have seen an amazing increase
in the number of applications. You guys have
been working really hard, and we're really
excited about that.
As we were thinking about the new application
style, we wanted to create a -- some guidelines
that would support the growing diversity of
applications. And to enable that diversity,
we created an icon system that has diverse
shapes, materials, and colors. And at the
same time we want to establish a few unifying
elements to help the system fit together,
and to raise the bar of quality for the visual
design in Android.
So some of the characteristics are the icons
are tactile. So even the more minimal icons
feel like they are made out of a material.
They are top-lit, matte, and forward facing,
which helps them work in some of the new 3D
launcher menus. And also to reduce the visual
complexity, we use synecdoche, which is where
we will take one component piece of an application
and use that to represent the whole application.
So for example, the settings icon is simply
one settings dial and not a picture of a whole
control panel. Or the calculator icon is simply
the equals key instead of a picture of an
entire calculator.
So to keep that simplicity. And again, our
highest goal is to support the diversity of
applications and brands in the marketplace.
So we are excited to see what the community
adds to the mix.
In fact, when we were designing this icon
set, we took a representative sample of unique
icons that people were making in the community
and mixed them together to see if it could
feel cohesive, and we feel like this new style
really does enable that expansion.
Okay. So to help developers get off the ground
with this new icon style, we're providing
launcher icon template kit. And let me show
you how it works.
So let's say that you have a vector-based
logo. You would like to apply it to your application.
So I am going to grab this square tile and
I might want to change it to match the color
of my brand. In this case, I like the green.
I will then simply add my vector art. Maybe
I am importing it from illustrator here. And
then apply some layer effects that are included
in the kit. And very quickly have a passible
logo. Or a passible icon based on my logo.
So we acknowledge that there will be a lot
of brands will want to take the rendering
much further with the icons, but we thought
that this would be a helpful way to help people
get started.
So, really, one of Android's strong points
is its flexibility. And we believe that it
should be true of the visuals as well.
So with enabling an icon system that encourages
diversity as well as applications that are
distinct and branded, that we can fulfill
this vision for Android. And I am going to
pass the baton next to Chris who is going
to show us an example of how these new design
patterns, plus customized branded assets,
can continue to tell the story.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris Nesladek: Hello. I am Chris Nesladek,
and I am here today to demo an application
which many of you probably have downloaded
that shows off the best of these patterns
and polish techniques that we recently shipped.
Let's get started looking at Twitter for Android,
shall we?
So we start with the dashboard firmly in place,
and as you can see, the one twist that we
have done with the dashboard immediately is
to use the goodness of live wallpapers that
we shipped in Android 2.1 and animate the
home screen.
Those are Twitter clouds and that's the Twitter
bird. And if you notice, it's fun and functional
and just a little bit more than just a home
orientation activity that Richard described
previously.
That bird is actually look at me right now,
and you can decide if that's strange or weird.
But I prefer to say that's cute.
Anyway.
Those are real-time trend bubbles as well.
And again, we have the action bar at the top
to orient the user.
So the next pattern I am going to demo is
obviously the action bar. Can someone tell
me what would be a primary activity for any
Twitter application?
>>> Tweet.
>>Chris Nesladek: There we go, tweet. So with
the new action bar pattern in place, I can
tap the tweet icon and get taken to the tweet
compose activity.
Now, here you can see that those most common
functions are actually on screen for the user,
like in view. But we haven't given up the
functionality of the main menu.
What I want to point out is that while you
can surface the most important actions, you
shouldn't forget about the richness of the
Android UI pattern to use the main menu. Rather,
using the main menu.
So you can quickly upload a photo if you want.
You can -- I am not going to do that, though.
You can take a picture, or you can add multiple
"at" user names with a picker that we implemented
as well, making it easier for you to tweet.
One other nice feature, by the way, I want
to call out is in the main menu, you can toggle
switch to direct message through this.
So let's go back to the dashboard, though.
You don't have to go back to the dashboard.
I will show you a little trick later. But
tap the Twitter logo which takes us to the
app home, and you are back on the dashboard.
Now, from the dashboard, the next pattern
is obviously visible, is the search bar.
Now, when you go to search -- unfortunately,
I should have search suggestions, but I don't,
as recommended. However, if you tap the upper
left you can pivot between tweets and people.
So with the new search bar corpora bubble
thingy, as I like to call it, anyway, search
suggestions are recommended as well as if
I did search for something, it would actually
hold my -- there it is. So there's suggestions.
Well done, implemented correctly. And then
if I search for Google I/O for tweets, it
will hold my history.
As we go back.
Photograph do that and tap. There it is. Implemented
correctly.
The next thing would be quick actions. My
favorite pattern. In fact, quick actions has
been a passion because for me, long press
is so powerful but was very destructive once
we surfaced it as a dialogue on top of the
data which you were trying to act on. So with
quick actions what we are able to do as you
can see in this activity there is an on screen
affordance. You tap it, and up pops a rail
of actions that are not covering the data
that you wish to act on.
Now, as mentioned previously by Richard, turning
off the ListView button element is recommended
so you can quickly let a user tap a link and
make that actionable for them, as well as
in this view don't forget to use the main
menu for any overflow functions that might
be hard to tap. There is a tweet meta data
link that's inside of this list view, but
sometimes people find that hard to hit so
as a designer view on map was put into the
main menu.
So we have done dashboard, action bar, search
bar, quick actions. Next up -- we are flying
through this. Dashboard, action bar, search
bar, quick actions, yep.
Next up is the companion widget.
The companion widget on the Twitter app was
implemented in two ways.
It was implemented as a large and a small
widget.
That button, it's not a -- it's not implemented
as just a button, but, rather, you have one
action associated with it.
For example, in the small widget, you can
tap this and be taken to a tweet compose to
reply to that tweet.
Or -- uh-oh.
We just lost it.
But it's back.
Or on a large widget, you can use that to
tweet something of your own.
All right.
So I've covered dashboard, action bar, search
bar, quick actions, as well as the on-screen
widgets.
The last two points I'd like to make to you
today before we take your questions is that
if you think about patterns, a good example
is to think about layering patterns into your
activities.
So if you look at our tweet -- our profile
section here, what you can see is, I just
tapped on the tweets in the upper left-hand
portion of the screen.
And that function is actually the search bar
pattern.
Ordinarily, as a designer, I might have chosen
to use tabs in this view to pivot on multiple
points, data sets.
However, when you think about it, that bubble
is more friendly and faster for some people,
and I don't have to actually ask a developer
to implement flickable tabs, which are a problem,
because, basically, a user can never know
how many different data sets exist.
So if you think about using patterns, try
to use them in creative ways.
Also, you can see that the action bar is laid
out on screen with quick actions here and
the main menu.
So we've been able to layer in more functionality
in a rich way, which is the Android user experience
in a nutshell.
And on top of that, what's even more important
is to think about, as Christian talked about,
polish.
And with polish, what you want to do, as you
can see -- we'll actually look at this side
by side -- you want to support multiple densities.
You're going to have to do a little bit of
tweakage with the assets, as we talked about.
On the left is the htpi version of the Twitter
app.
And on the right is the mdpi app.
The mdpi portion of this was equally challenging.
But basically if you spend the time and the
pixels, you can get an app to look great on
both densities.
So with that, I'd like to take all -- we'd
like to take your questions right now and
see what's on your mind.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Jim Palmer: Thanks, Chris.
We can also invite Mike (saying name) up on
stage to answer questions.
Before we take questions from the audience,
we want to do the Q&A nerd question.
Who can identify the rhetorical device?
>>> (inaudible).
>>Jim Palmer: It is, indeed.
Also a movie by Walter Kaufman.
Here's your SYNECDOCHE, which is a rhetorical
device for associating something, a part for
the whole or something closely related to
a part for the whole.
Great get there.
Let's switch over to questions.
Let's start with a few from the floor, and
then we'll also -- can you bring up the Wave
so we can look.
Yes.
>>> Hello.
Roland Schweitzer.
I'm App Weather.
I agree that context menus are destructive
from the point of view that they often cover
up the data that you're trying to act on.
But from a developer's point of view, they're
nice because they're part of the framework.
So will action bars, quick action bars and
that sort of pattern become part of the -- the
underlying Android frameworks to make it easy
for us to implement on those?
>>Jim Palmer: Let Mike take this one.
>>> Mike: Probably.
The pattern that we have been following is,
applications are usually a little ahead of
the framework, because that's where the pioneering
work goes on in terms of UI patterns.
So the framework then catches up to what we
determine to be sort of the common or emerging
patterns.
The action bars look like a winner.
So making that easy to support in applications
is something that we're working on adding
to the framework.
>>Jim Palmer: Okay.
Thank you.
Let's take one from this side over here.
>>> That was it.
>>Jim Palmer: That was it.
Great.
Let me take one off the Wave.
The second one here, what's Google's stance
on hardware manufacturers overlaying their
own UI enhancements over stock Android?
Is this something which will be discouraged
in the future?
No, actually, we love the fact that Android's
open and people can do their own things with
it.
We think it's great for the -- both the products
and for us as designers to see what other
people do with it.
So, you know, we're perfectly happy with that
as the plan going forward.
Okay.
Over here.
>>> Yeah.
So I do a lot of rapid prototyping on various
devices and lately have been doing a lot on
Android.
And one of the things I notice is that in
order to build really rich UIs quickly, I
found it easier just to throw up a Web view
and use HTML, CSS, and JavaScript to get a
lot of stuff that's available to us on the
Web.
I'm curious what your thoughts are on that
approach and if you guys use a lot of the
stuff that's associated with the Web technologies
and will be bringing it to native code.
>>Jim Palmer: So for sure certainly the UI
team has done some prototyping using Web views
and certain tools that will allow us to sort
of put it on the phone in a Web view.
There are definitely some differences in the
behaviors you get with Web views, obviously,
than the full elements.
But it's great for doing basic sizing and
seeing how the images look as we go forward.
I don't know, in the long term, you know,
impact of Web views, I think Mike can step
in and add color here, too, we certainly do
mix those in our apps today.
There are certain apps that, you know, are
done with native base framework and we use
that to get the effect.
I think you'll probably continue to see that
kind of mixing going forwards.
>>> Mike: If you've used our GMail application,
when you're viewing a GMail conversation,
you're seeing one big Web view, because so
much of the content is already HTML formatted.
We use the Web view for that display.
But it fits well with the rest of the application.
>>Jim Palmer: Okay.
On this side.
>>> What guidelines would you share with developers
who are trying to bring an application to
mobile and paring down the feature set so
that it is mobile-specific but also discoverable?
Because oftentimes if you pack too many things
in, your users can't -- won't latch onto the
mobile version of it.
If you back too few things in, again, they
won't use it.
So what balance or guidelines would you share?
>>Richard Fulcher: I think the first question
you need to ask yourself is kind of given
that the user's now in this mobile context,
has the set of tasks kind of changed?
What are the most important things for them,
given that they may be kind of out and about
and not kind of at home?
So the recommendation I would make is kind
of think about of all of the things you can
support, which tasks make the most sense and
provide the most value in the mobile context
as kind of a first-pass strategy for how you
would scale some of that back.
I guess the second point would be that, you
know, we have -- a couple of times we have
mentioned that we want you to bring the most
important things to the forefront.
You can still wind up supporting kind of a
lot of deep, kind of darker, less frequently
used stuff, but just kind of don't -- don't
pollute the most classic use cases by kind
of pushing them forward into the screen.
That's a great reason to use quick actions,
great reason to use the menu drawer to support
those types of behaviors.
>>Jim Palmer: Chris, do you have any color?
You took Twitter and turned it into a really
great app.
Any thoughts on that process for just how
you did that?
>>Chris Nesladek: Make sure you spend a lot
of time thinking about what's the most important
thing.
>>Jim Palmer: Yeah, I mean, I think that really
is what it comes down to, is you have to really
think hard about what is your primary user
story or user use case and make sure you don't
end up talking yourself into that.
We have this sort of joke that, you know,
sometimes, you know, people will argue for
any one particular feature which you can make
very rational arguments for.
Then you look back, you know, a month later
and go, whoa, how did we end up adding 20
things?
If you look at the back from how you ended
up somewhere, sometimes every single step
looks logical, but when you look at the totality,
it's like, that didn't make sense.
So really sticking closely to, you know, what
really is the essence of your app, that's
the best guideline we can give.
>>> Mike: Let me add something to that.
I don't know the particulars of the problem
you're trying to solve, but Android has a
couple of unique tools that can help with
the complexity of a user with a small screen
trying to manage some complex space.
In particular, the widgets and background
tasks and notifications can help with that.
So by having the device doing the work rather
than the user doing the work, and only surfacing
the things that are interesting to the user,
you can prevent the user from having to navigate
a lot of complexity.
So if something shows up in the notification
bar when something interesting happened, I
may not have to navigate at all.
I can just let background processing and notifications
have the content come to me rather than having
to build a rich, complicated navigation experience
on the device.
That's another thing to consider in the Toolkit.
>>Jim Palmer: Okay.
Let me address another one from the Wave here.
How can Android itself help developers design
more stylish UI for apps?
One thing I think for sure is what Mike was
saying.
Our pattern here is do a lot of exploration
in the apps.
And we want to be able to push those innovations
that we think really are meaningful down into
the framework so that they'll be there.
As Christian was noting, though, as well,
we are aware that we want to help you guys
more.
So we are looking at publishing some of the
stuff we use, like his icon library and other
kinds of things up to the site so that, you
know, what we're doing, you know, we share
as much as possible with you.
Those are the, you know, two sort of concrete
things we're doing right now.
Okay.
Over here.
>>> I have a question about making things
that are clickable obvious that they're clickable.
So if I have a ListView, maybe some of the
things have additional detail, some don't.
How do I indicate that?
Or on the Twitter application, to me, it wasn't
readily apparent that the Twitter logo was
clickable.
>>> Right.
>>> Is there some -- is there patterns around
that?
>>Chris Nesladek: Well, frankly, that's -- this
is the first application that actually ships
with these patterns that we believe will be,
you know -- come in the future.
So that upper left-hand portion of the screen
is meant to be clickable and an app home.
Actually, in a hidden way, if you look at
our market application previous to Froyo,
it actually was tappable, not visible, again,
exactly well for users, but you can hit that
and then go back to the first place in the
Market home as well.
So it's just something we think over time,
you know, it's a Web style of UI innovation
that we're trying to really push forward here.
So if you think about Web sites, in the left-hand
portion of the screen is generally where you
return home.
>>Jim Palmer: Yeah, it's a fine line.
There's partially a genre effect here, which
is as the patterns become established, that's
what people learn.
In other products, they have other genres,
things that we thought were obvious had to
be learned on those other platforms.
I think there's another element to what you're
talking about, which is the visual -- they
all look clickable.
And this is one of the things we're talking
about a lot from the visual design perspective,
as Chris, you know, you saw in the visual
design in the Twitter app, all the icons didn't
necessarily have big frames around them.
There's a line there between making something
that looks maybe more like a background or
a piece of art versus, you know, something
that's clickable.
We think there's a way to cut that that makes
it still look clickable, as well as not always
requiring it to be completely, you know, buffed
out with all the Chrome.
So I think, you know, that we're going to
see some more from us on that going forward.
The direction, I think, though ultimately,
should be as many things as possible on the
screen should be clickable just because people
do experiment and expect things to happen
when you touch.
Okay.
Over here.
>>> Yes, what are the guidelines around orientation
support?
And the Twitter app is wonderful, but if you
have a Droid and you look at that home screen
sideways --
>>Chris Nesladek: I'm glad you're saying that,
because as a developer, you have a choice.
And so do we.
We chose not to support that landscape orientation.
>>> And then there's another example in the
Android, this default dialer that when you're
in call, it's portrait only as well.
There's some examples on that.
Is it just simply up to a developer design
decision say you don't have to support the
orientations?
Or what's the thinking on it?
>>> Mike: Generally, the more you can use
it in both orientations, the better.
But there are certain applications, a lot
of games just won't make sense rotated, you
know.
They need to be in a portrait layout.
For the dialer, there isn't actually a design
reason why that thing doesn't work in landscape.
It's mostly implementation time.
We haven't had time to create a quality landscape
experience.
So we thought portrait only is better than
lame landscape.
Because that thing is -- it's got a lot of
steps, and it's pretty complex.
But, in general, users like using the device
in both orientations.
You saw the wealth of different devices out
there.
So, you know, people are using these things
in a lot of different ways.
So the more flexibility you give the user,
probably the better.
>>> Especially in the case where the device
has a keyboards.
That's something that we've required with
client requirements, they want to have that
keyboard and have it shift to landscape.
>>> Mike: Exactly.
It's not optional, you have to use landscape
to use the keyboard.
So you have a great experience there.
>>Jim Palmer: Let me address another one from
the Wave here.
Actually, we get asked this a bunch.
You know, this one is specifically, how is
Android approaching resolution, scaling, phone,
the tablet.
So, you know, we spent some time in this session
talking about mdpi and hdpi.
We're not at this point rolling out a hardware
profile for larger devices like tablets and
beyond.
However, we are actively working on that.
And I think one thing I'd like to sort of
discuss is that there's actually a couple
of complexities in here, which is why we're
still working on this.
One part of this is more than just a resolution
scaling.
It has to do with actual layout scaling.
There are certain apps you can imagine like
a browser where the layout differences are
very minimal.
Other apps, it's more complex how you might
want to address that layout change.
In addition, just to add a little wrinkle
to it all, mdpi and hdpi aren't the only two
things that matter as you move to a tablet
or larger screen size.
Just merely taking the density, tablets, for
example, tend to be used further back.
If you just take the same exact images and
use them, they may not look right even using
the current one.
So we're trying to evaluate what the right
set of things is.
Currently, you can already support these devices,
and there are tablets out there today.
I think, you know, the right thing for us
to do is really look at all the issues and
come out with what we think the right answer
is.
So nothing yet to announce now, but, believe
me, we understand, and we're definitely working
on that.
Okay.
Question from over here.
>>> First off, Chris, thanks for making a
decent-looking Twitter app for the Android
platform.
[ Applause ]
>>> Good job, Chris.
>>Chris Nesladek: Thanks.
>>> And Virgil.
>>> And now we can't standstill.
Is conversation view going to happen?
Because that is the -- that is the key feature
for a lot of us out there.
>>> What?
>>> Conversation view.
Tweets aren't an island.
They're just part of a stream.
>>Chris Nesladek: I can't hear you that well.
>>> I'm sorry.
This is a short-people mike.
Conversation view inside of a Twitter app
for Google, is that coming?
>>Chris Nesladek: So the Twitter app, we're
hoping to open-source this.
We don't know when TBD.
But you, as developers, will be able to take
that code and use that activity, yes.
>>> All right.
Thanks.
That's all I have.
>>Chris Nesladek: You're welcome.
>>Jim Palmer: Okay.
Over here.
>>> Yeah.
The Android SDK integration with Eclipse is,
like, really lousy.
I was wondering if you guys had any plans
to improve that.
[ Applause ]
>>> Especially on the XL UI builder is completely
unusable.
Interface builder is great.
Do you have any plans on doing something like
that?
>>> Mike: I actually didn't hear.
That I heard something is lousy, but I didn't
hear what.
>>> Android SDK integration with Eclipse,
really atrocious.
>>> Mike: Yes.
We realize that.
And we -- we have people working on coming
up with more polished and more refined tools.
But we're not ready to announce those yet.
>>Jim Palmer: Okay.
We're winding down here.
Just a couple questions to go.
>>> What's the Android policy on 3D?
Is there any support for 3D coming out?
Not, you know, the one with the class.
I'm talking more about rich 3D, something
a little higher than a bird but not on the
glasses kind of thing, but -- do you have
any --
>>Jim Palmer: Well, so the most recent release,
you know, we have a couple of examples where
we're using 3D, the gallery, which is the
photo gallery, there's an effect in there
which does some 3D stuff, as well as the new
app launcher in Nexus One has a 3D effect.
The tools in there, GL is in there.
We can go into more about that.
We're all, of course, interested in exploring
that.
3D is a tricky thing to get right to make
sure it's still usable and over time something
is delightful up to the first couple times
doesn't get annoying over multiple use.
But I'll say, yes, we're interested in it.
And the base technology is in there now.
Mike, is there anything else to add on 3D
technology?
>>> Mike: No.
>>Jim Palmer: I think that's it.
One more.
>>> Lots of Android developers also do other
platform, like iPhone or BlackBerry development.
But for business side, I also need to support
multiple platforms.
My question is for the design patterns, is
there any plan to promote to other platform
beyond Android or just the Android?
>>Jim Palmer: Yeah, I think at this point,
we're really, you know, looking at developing
the right patterns for our platforms.
I know for developers, you know, you're developing
for multiple platforms.
I think our recommendation is, as always,
you know, from a design point of view, it's
more work, but it's best to fit in with the
platform that you're developing your apps
for.
So in the cases where there are different
genres or different, you know, styles in those
platforms, it's better to do that.
Oftentimes, just moving something over as
is doesn't quite work the same.
You'll feel a little bit out of sorts.
So, you know, we're not planning right now
on taking our patterns and exporting them
to other platforms.
Okay.
Looks like that's it for today.
So thank you, everyone, for coming.
And for all the support.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris Nesladek: Hang on, guys.
Do you guys -- who wants two collectibles?
We have two left.
When was Android founded?
Who knows?
>>> (Off mike).
>>Chris Nesladek: No.
I don't hear it yet.
2005.
Who said it?
>>> Right here.
>>Chris Nesladek: All right.
Next.
One more.
What's a good question?
Mike, what do you have?
Something about Android.
>>> Scaling ratio.
>>Christian Robertson: That's it.
>>Chris Nesladek: What's the magic scaling
ratio?
All right.
Thank you.